fox la's bill mugen has more on that
story for us tonight hey bill
hey tucker good evening to you that's
exactly right our new progressive
district attorney here in l.a george
gascon suffered a pretty major setback
in court yesterday that's when a judge
ruled that some of his new progressive
reforms are not only illegal
they are also unethical so if we can
pull up some video right now i'll
explain
starting with his policy on california's
three strikes law california's three
strikes law
was voted in overwhelmingly by
california voters
back in the 1990s and the strikes law
essentially allows prosecutors to seek
harsher sentences for repeat criminal
offenders and
on day one in office george gascon
issued a directive to all of his
prosecutors saying
we are not going to enforce the through
the three strikes law
because it's my opinion that it is
racist and it is unconstitutional
he then started forcing his prosecutors
to read a statement in court
essentially agreeing with his legal
opinion and the prosecutor
union had a big problem with that so
they sued him they essentially sued
their own boss
and yesterday a judge ruled against
george gaskin and sided with the union
writing in part quote from james
chalfont the judge
the district attorney's disregard of the
three strikes law plead and prove
requirement is
unlawful as is requiring deputy da's to
seek dismissal of pending sentencing
enhancements
without a lawful basis the special
directive statement that prosecutors are
required to read in court
is legally inaccurate and incomplete and
reading this statement in court without
correction
is unethical so a big loss for gascon on
that
the judge went on to issue an order
restricting george gascon
from not following the three strikes law
he says just because it's your opinion
that you don't want to enforce it
doesn't mean
you can't not enforce it so gascon must
now start enforcing it
us talk to the vice president of the d.a
union out here they said they were
relieved by this ruling from the judge
they feel vindicated and they say george
gascon's directives
were causing a big problem for them take
a listen does it kind of put us in
this impossible position do we follow
his directives or do we follow the law
and the court clearly said well you need
to follow the law
and george gascon released a statement
yesterday in response to all of this
saying he knew he was going to have a
tough job
trying to change what he says is an
outdated
racist system here in los angeles of
mass incarceration he says
he plans to appeal this decision to a
higher court
tucker bill thanks for that report
one of one of the great reporters in a
state that badly needs more